if ghosts exist we would have some form
of
one-tenth of some proof well we went in
a haunted tunnel and people say they
could hear a voice and there was like a
weird silhouette
[ __ ] stupid of course they [ __ ]
want to hear they hear what they want to
hear
there's a silhouette of joey on the wall
in the tunnel yeah that was kind of
creepy that was creepy do we really
think right
yeah silhouette can be done by anything
though everything is explainable i think
people just want there to be something
more because
they take comfort in knowing that you
know there's something just easily
explains why they're dumb
if i don't know something i'm like i'm
just dumb i don't know what it is it's
definitely not a ghost
do you think this mystical flying [ __ ] i
would have no idea what it is why would
i know
it's difficult
did you see the whole are you tweeting
about this i swear the ufo stuff right
oh yeah yeah yeah it's kind of
interesting
i think it's super [ __ ] cool yeah
there's something there we so
technologically advanced we can't get it
i love how
i love how people we just accepted that
this is ufos now some nonsense like
they just took some nonsense the cia was
like yeah so by the way uh
ufos do exist don't panic but we just
don't know what it is
yeah i mean that's literally a
definition of a ufo
why is nobody ufo stands for
unidentified flying
object and they couldn't identify it
therefore
by definition it is literally a ufo for
like what 80 years we were like a bunch
of nonsense just a bunch of hearsay you
know because it would be like one p
or something you know we wouldn't have
we talked about ufos are you talking
about aliens because there's
plenty of ufos in the history of earth
that have
ufos that do like weird [ __ ] i guess i
don't know that's most ufos
yeah but we don't we don't really have
anything that like before that was
confirmed to be like actually like
like ufo how do you know though well we
didn't know until cia told us that now
there is in the report it says that
there's you know there's these
vehicles that move yeah i think i think
that report nasa was saying that like
yeah we've known about this for like the
past 50 years the thing is if you you
know if you
if they had a secret yeah they kept it a
secret because they didn't work because
it's just weird that like suddenly like
by the way when we all called you all
made you look
[ __ ] well it kind of seemed like soft
disclosure like very great
i feel like it was just weird that
nobody spoke about it nobody was like oh
that's weird okay
i mean what's because we're so limited
on the information how are we supposed
to react to it because like it's it's
not the first time
you've probably seen some weird [ __ ]
footage of it
it always looks like so fast i mean i
mean i guarantee the majority of it is
fake
yeah 100 yeah i mean i i would think the
majority of it is fake as well but i'm
sure like
there are some that are on the same
level as that cia footage yeah
that just were real and no one can
explain them
hence hence the term ufo right yeah but
it's normally synonymous with aliens
though and stuff like that right so
that's what it would normally
tend to would be in the same kind of if
someone's like i'm into ufos you're like
stay the [ __ ] away
you know they're [ __ ] investigating
well that's like that's part of the
problem right there's stigma around it
yeah well yeah
people who believe that [ __ ] normally
well same thing with ghosts right yeah
i'm sure there's aliens out there on
some planet if we manage to survive
and do the weird [ __ ] that we're doing
on earth i'm sure i mean look like i
believe in like aliens and stuff but i
don't believe in those like [ __ ]
ufos crash landed and onto earth and
they you know aliens came in contact do
you believe in ghosts
i do yeah why because i've had like
paranormal experiences myself
like like what so one of the scariest
ones i had was in
in sydney there's this place uh in manly
called the quarantine
center and it was during world war one i
think
it was the place where like all the
soldiers used to stop by
from overseas to get quarantined in case
they had like right illnesses and stuff
like that
so a lot of people died at this place
naturally right um
and they have like these like nighttime
tours for this place that you can go and
like you can go to like the hospitals
and like all it's very
creepy stuff right uh so i went with my
sister once for her birthday i think it
was
and my sister has like this weird i
guess you call it
sixth sense if you will you know take
that take that how you will all right
take that how you will quivering and
jealousy yeah
take that how you will but like she she
has like that whatever that is
um and there was this one moment where
she was inside we were inside the
hospital and i don't have anything like
that i don't
pretend to feel like oh i feel a ghost
present or anything like that i just
find it fascinating
but then we went into this like
particular like i think it was like a
nursery
and my sister just stopped and just
immediately started breaking down crying
and i was like what's wrong well it's
just a dark room like you've been
through this entire hospital and it's
this room where she just suddenly breaks
down she's like i can't
i can't move past this point and she
just couldn't explain it there was
she just felt something in this one
particular room and then later we found
out
that was the place where they would
euthanize all the soldiers that
couldn't survive whatever illness it was
like that's where like all the soldiers
like
basically died and i was like okay look
you can believe in like sixth sense or
and all that kind of [ __ ] all you want
but you have to admit
that's pretty [ __ ] terrifying
especially when you're there in person
i mean you know because i'm again i
don't really believe in any of that
that's just coincidence i used to work
at a haunted castle and my colleagues
always said they saw ghosts
but i'd be like like someone up the
window like there's occasionally
presents but no it's a window
when we expect something to be there we
you know our mind is the biggest [ __ ]
joke that's ever been played like we we
our mind tricks us in so many ways like
of course like i'm sure there's moments
where it's like you know you just psych
yourself out right
and you just like you just think you've
seen something because you're already in
that mindset
but yeah you know there are some
instances where i'm like oh that's
actually kind of creepy like
i don't know if it's a ghost i don't
know if it's sixth sense but it's
something yeah i mean i i
think there is something there there's
too many there are too many things i
feel that can't be
can't be explained like the ufo for
example you don't go through an entire
hospital and then
immediately start breaking down in a
room but i might if i were honestly
known for trauma you could do that if
your head space is there right you might
have seen so much but she was fine
throughout the entire hospital except
for this one room what it might have
been building up but
my car you know it's like when people
give like
people people don't the mind is a really
[ __ ] weird thing that we don't
understand
you know like people give witness
testimony at like trials and stuff and
they
they 100 swear they saw stuff that they
didn't see yeah right so it's like
i don't know i i find that we like to be
able to easily explain everything even
when we have no explanations like we
don't have an explanation we're like oh
it's ghosts or some [ __ ] i'm like well
that's just another
way for you to cope because you want an
explanation you know but maybe you just
don't know maybe we don't have the
capacity to know
what that noise is what i find i find it
fascinating that we don't
know right and that there is a mystery
behind them that no one has really
figured out is it just in your head or
is there something
we're pretty [ __ ] stupid people in
general yeah
[Music]
and for some reason we like to think
that we can think of every single answer
to everything we most certainly can
[ __ ] not i mean for
how many [ __ ] years we were just
fighting with sticks and stones oh yeah
why aren't we twitter's verified i mean
yeah
sometimes people explain [ __ ] to me that
i'm like this terrible [ __ ] like i can
tell like
like you know there are a lot of like
these kinds of like mystical mythical
things where it's like
that's kind of too i i feel like what's
really muddied the water is just
how you know some people have obviously
monetized this you see like
you see like these ghosts uh these
ghosts like reality tv shows and i'm
just like this is just
translation investigation how are you
supposed to take this seriously anymore
like i felt like i've heard genuinely
like
things that just can't be explained and
i've also experienced some of that
myself so like
it's it's kind of like you know i i
don't think
that i would blame anyone for not
believing in ghosts believing in ghosts
i just feel like
the entire perception around it has been
warped because
of how this how these things have been
presented and the reality tv shows
around it and these the people you kind
of see
believing in these kinds of things kinds
of things right but i feel like yeah
like i absolutely don't blame people for
like seeing those shows and being like
it's all [ __ ] like it's all it's
always
it's entertaining whatever it's
entertainment whatever but like you know
i personally believe in it because it's
more fun and interesting
i just think that oh there might be
something there
i mean i i don't know if i believe in
you ufos there's nothing to believe in
they are real
if you say aliens then that's a leap of
faith yeah you know you're starting to
make that
yeah i guarantee guaranteed we're
recording this right now there's going
to be someone
in the comment section that has a story
that just can't there will be there
always is there always is but then i
also also find that
you know i think that there's something
in your life that makes you more likely
to believe in them
like there's some something in your
personality or emotional something that
happened in your life that tends to make
you more likely to be
receptive to that stuff right i mean i
don't know why i'm so [ __ ]
pessimistic
but i know when this comes up i just
don't say anything because i know that
this is one of those topics people who
believe in it
you just they're so emotional about it
and so invested yeah i'm not i'm really
not for people get really offended when
you're like
how dare you and it's like so i just
stopped i just i i never like if i meet
someone who's like i have this ghost
experience i'm like oh great
yeah i mean it's kind of like on the
same level as like religion right
because
obviously someone who believes in ghosts
had a very personal experience and
obviously that meant a lot to them and
it's like
obviously you know if they say their
experience it's kind of like it's kind
of a bit of a dignity
um actually i don't want to invalidate
how anyone felt
or experienced anything but but also on
the second time on the other hand you
know you want to be logical
about things and you want to try and you
know i think i think healthy skepticism
is good right like
just just you know i i can't stand
people parties are like you're wrong
you're religious [ __ ] go home
like i can't like on the contrary though
i can't stand people who are like
explain everything as like supernatural
or yes or whatever it's so annoying and
i'm just like no no no like
i get some situations but like you know
you're you're getting divorced with your
wife was not because of the ghost
it's like there's nothing supernatural